that was the first time that I initially
told him that I loved him was at Cairo
do well he likes to yodel I can almost
cry describing her she's the love of my
life I fell in love with her as she was
getting out of a taxi the first time I
ever saw her
[Music]
well my friends and talk to us for two
years they didn't like the idea that was
going out and definitely didn't like the
idea of married an Italian wrong cast
wrong culture wrong religion wrong
everything so my grandfather was the
patriarch of the family when I told him
I was dating Aaron it was almost like it
broke his heart to a point where he went
he actually went to my pastor and said
this is against the Bible my parents
were a little bit more leery when it
came to me dating especially outside of
my race they were worried that maybe if
if we didn't get along that the n-word
would pop out a car drove by and there's
these teenagers in there and they rolled
the window down and yelled Chinese and
white ain't right and I got kind of mad
Allah put that what the hell and she
said yeah I mean I'm Korean what what's
wrong with him and you would think a
group that is as marginalized as the gay
community would be completely
comfortable with an interracial couple
couple but you know privately they'll
they'll say things to me that or a
little appropriate well you know Matt he
you know he likes the brothers or once
you go black you never go back
or the black of the berry the sweeter
the juice I mean I've heard them all
hasn't emeritus International changed me
whole has married to changed me and now
after so many years totally dominated by
my wife exactly it's Marilyn I don't
wake up in the morning and think like oh
here's my black husband and I'm half
Indian and we're about to start our
interracial day I just love kind of
experiencing their culture even if we're
around his mother and she's cooking a
dish that he grew up eating biscuits and
gravy I just fell in love with that so
it was like I've never had any before I
was ready for this and you always use my
products
oh you do use my black hair care
products that isn't that is son not true
what would I say to somebody who didn't
believe in interracial relationships
it's probably not for you then why do we
have to put the tag on as interracial
marriage should they just be a marriage
when she's talking to me I'm not
thinking like I'm listening to a
Filipino I'm listen Anjali according to
science race is barely even a thing I
mean we're all just humans if you meet
somebody and you do get along and you
have a ton in common
why should race matter
[Music]